but Duchess of Cambridge has released a
video calling for an end to the stigma
surrounding children's mental health
skies royal correspondent Rhiannon Mills
reports the challenges facing children
in the UK today can often fill
overwhelming we don't often hear from
the Duchess of Cambridge but now she's
asking other parents to talk about their
children a mental health the stigma
around mental health means that many
children do not get the help that they
so badly need this needs to change no
one would feel embarrassed about seeking
help for a child if they broke their arm
and we really should be equally ready to
support a child coping with emotional
difficulties the video launches the UK's
first children's mental health week run
by one of her charities a place to be
while she soon going to be a mum of two
a big focus of Kate's royal work is
helping other children affected by
addiction neglect and other emotional
issues Nikki Mattox is now studying
psychology in her early teens suffered
with depression and often couldn't get
the support that she needed I think
there is nowhere near enough help for
young people at the moment because I
don't think it's recognised that
children can actually get depressed in
children like children and young people
can and they do they may experience
mental illness but I don't think that's
recognised enough new research found
almost 1/3 of parents would feel
embarrassed if their child wanted
counselling in school while one in five
wouldn't encourage their children to
have counselling even if they asked for
it and it was dads who were more likely
to feel embarrassed at oldfield primary
school in Ealing they already give
pupils dedicated time to talk about
their feelings if they want to it's
really important that if a child is
anxious even about a friendship that
they just have someone to talk to
because sorting out those anxious
feelings that come then in later life
leads to bigger problems is really
important
while dealing with the issue of mental
health isn't always easy for mums and
dads having someone like Kate on board
will at least get people talking
Rhiannon Mills Sky News LaLanne Halligan
is a director of the parent practice
that she joins us now good morning to
you and we heard there at the end of the
report it is something very difficult
for parents to actually face up to isn't
it I think mental health is a really
scary topic for those parents and I
think when we talk about mental health
it's important to be clear about what
we're talking about and it can manifest
itself in lots of different ways that
can be quite subtle and a child not
getting out of bed in the morning and
may be overworking over exercising even
overeating and then the larger
manifestations can quickly come which
may be the the self-harm the addiction
and perhaps the eating disorders and I
think it's a very very scary topic and
we're finding a lot more children are
suffering from this behind closed doors
in kind of middle-class affluent
families and I think people really do
need help to know what to do
and what we say at the parent practice
is that prevention is much better than
cure but how can a parent be certain
that their child is having mental health
difficulties and they're not just
dealing with a particularly difficult
child and that's their personality say
we hope not to get to the stage where
there's serious mental health which is
the self-harm and eating disorders but
the biggest curve top tip for parents is
that we absolutely have to be what we
call an emotional coach for your child
it's really important to listen and to
validate children's feelings and this is
a hard thing to do a very simple example
if your child says I don't want to go to
school in the morning it's very tempting
as a parent to kind of dismiss and deny
that feeling and to say oh don't be
silly
schools fine you love it you're just
going through a bad time and it it's
very easy to kind of dismiss that
feeling now if I show something
yes it's where that is the correct
response that a child just thinks well I
don't really want to go to school today
but there's nothing wrong on a wider
scale there may be nothing wrong but
it's really important that that first
sign we just open up reach out to them
and listen to them and I think that's a
hard thing I think parents really
struggle to listen to their children
they are going to go to school unless
they're seriously unwell or or ill but
but we need to
really reached out and listen to them
and I think it's very difficult for us
to do that none of us want our children
to feel sad and overwhelmed
maybe not coping with life may be lonely
with friendship difficulties and and
what we says if you name it to tame it
what you're doing there is helping your
child develop an emotional literacy
because emotional IQ is at the heart
have been a successful young adult so if
we're going to develop children with a
kind of really strong sense of
self-worth with a really robust
emotional intelligence I think a lot of
work has to happen in the home and
that's where we as parents struggle I
struggled myself it's very difficult
with these skills knowing how to react
how to listen well you don't know
whether it's just a one-off I don't want
to go to school or whether there's a
real deeper implication there you
worried though that you might be
encouraging some parents to be walking
on eggshells because they really don't
know how to deal with their child
whether this is a perfectly normal
emotional whether it's an indication
that something might be wrong sometimes
it's just discipline isn't it that's a
really interesting point you make and
walking on eggshells kind of implies to
me that many of us have parents have
kind of lost the ability to be in charge
we're a bit anxious about what to do
what to say how to discipline and and
what we deliver at the parent practice
and we listen to parents day in day out
through our classes and workshops is
that they are struggling in kind of xxi
society where digital hygiene is a huge
issue and people don't quite know how to
discipline it it's a loaded question you
burst but again to give another maybe
relevant example is the digital world
has a huge impact on children's sense of
self-worth and if we find that they are
succumbing to too much online activity
that will absolutely impact on their
mental health so to tie up with what
you're saying we as parents need to be
very clear about what our own digital
modeling is and values I feel a little
embarrassed here because you know
sometimes my mobile phone it's kind of
surgically attached to my hip and and if
we model that very example that's
but I struggle sometimes with my own
digital usage so top tip for parents out
there and it's half a drop zone yeah so
at mealtimes bedtime definitely just
know everything it just let your child
drop that that digital and gadget in the
drop zone do not let them take into
their bedroom I think the one
certainties but yeah parenting is a
minefield it's difficult and there's no
handbook so it's missing very bad it's
messy Elaine thank you very much for
coming in pleasure